today we are announcing the Google
assistant to have an ongoing to a
dialogue with Google we think of this as
building each user their own individual
Google who directed the revenant the
revenue was directed by Alejandro
Gonzalez Inarritu
and you can follow that up with the
question show me his awards and Google
could pick that conversation up and
return the right answer our aspiration
is to make the assistant useful and
enjoyable in one of the most important
places in your world where you spend
time with your family this is Google
home Google home is a Wi-Fi speaker that
streams music directly from the cloud so
you get the highest quality playback and
it lets you control your video content
too we're also designing Google home to
support the most popular home networking
systems daydream is our platform for
high quality mobile virtual reality and
in it are all of the ingredients you
need to create incredible immersive VR
experiences we've created a reference
design for headsets that will work
seamlessly with daydream ready phones
everyone thinks about headsets but the
controller how you interact with VR it's
just as important but we've been working
on a controller for daydream looks like
this we've built an orientation sensor
so it knows where it's pointing how it's
turning you can do some pretty awesome
things with it
I'd like to introduce you to duo a
simple one-to-one video calling app for
everyone it's fast and performs well
even on slow networks today I'm sharing
a preview of our biggest platform update
yet Android wear 2.0 Android wear
already has thousands of watch faces you
can download and now we're making them
even more useful by letting any watch
face show data from any app we look
forward to building this - future
together with all of you thank you for
joining us at Google IO